first up she is the tv personality who
after 11 seasons
is the last of the original co-host to
leave the talk please welcome sharon
osborne is over here
oh let's see see they still love you
hello hi hello
how are you oh yeah well that's
look at that
that's nice that's great aren't you glad
you came yeah just to hear that i know
well obviously you're here to talk about
brexit now do you believe if the
no no uh so i've been hearing about how
all the
people around your little scandal have
been doing how are you
is what i wanted to ask first of all
first of all um
it's so many different things i'm angry
i'm hurt
but you always were a strong one oh i'm
a fighter oh i we know that one so
i'm like yeah
well let's do a quick recap of the
tragic events of 310.
uh so on your ironically uh titled show
the talk
yes you were talking and uh
and if there's one lesson from this is
that's not allowed anymore
uh so i just want to say my view is
nothing happened on the tour we'll get
to other stuff but on
your show i don't think anything
happened because what happened was a few
weeks before
maybe the week before i don't know i
remember i watched it uh meghan markle
and prince harry gave their interview
with oprah
okay then your friend pierce morgan he's
a commentator in britain
he said he didn't believe things that
meghan markle said
right and then on your show you said
well he's a good friend of mine
and i don't necessarily agree with his
opinion but he is entitled to his
opinion
exactly so he was called a racist and
lost his job and you were called a
racist and lost your job do i have it
right
you got it right that's exactly how it
went right
who's the racist and why this is what
i'm trying to figure out
have you me me too okay me too
i've been called so many things in my
life
i am so used to being cool names but a
racist is one
i will not take yeah it's an insult
if you're not one
you